von hey leute was geht aufwärts mit
compal neuen video
ich bin gerade mit hertha zum auto und
zwar ist heute ein richtig geiler tag
die sonne strahlt das wetter schön
geiles auto
wer viele preis dass düsseldorf ich hab
mir gedacht nicht durch ein bisschen mit
ab und zu deswegen gibt's von mir
einfach mein block ist ja auch was
schönes ich hoffe ihr freut euch ein
bisschen drüber
falls ja könnte gern jetzt schon nach
oben da lassen wir haben richtig gute
laune
ja ich halte euch auf dem laufenden
dieses auto ist so schön so man kocht
die ganze zeit darauf und wir gucken
einfach die ganzen drauf was passiert
direkt falsch gefahren
dazu müssen wir unseren untersuchungen
zum halter nur 6
ja
da ließ
interessiert war
sowas
der fällt wie ein besoffener auf jeden
fall wenn man hand raus war
es ist so warnt raus voll krass war das
fenster runter
aber es schon ordentlich was los haben
schon fotos gemacht paar süße mädchen
getroffen
wir melden uns ja leute was geht ab wir
sind jetzt auf jeden fall hier
angekommen
da ist der rote teppich rede doch gerade
hier mit mal gucken wenn ich alles noch
so treffe ich habe schon ein paar leute
gesehen die schon länger nicht mehr
gesehen habe ist immer cool und wir
sehen uns ja leute was die wir sind
jetzt in der halle angekommen
auf jeden fall geil aus
die haben jetzt hab ich so einen krieg
seit monaten liefen aus der ist wohl
sehr befreundet
ich habe meine freundin seine freundin
mein neues
leute wir sind jetzt vom ölpreis weg
jetzt geht's eigentlich auf die
abzuschalten über under grad schon
müssen jetzt das auto umparken der vogel
hat was bekommen können
na ja auf jeden fall
ich wollte nur sagen das kann ich jetzt
leider nicht mehr film na ja auf jeden
fall gehen jetzt vielleicht zurück wir
bestimmen schwieriger abend aber ich
muss dann auch denken zu übergehen
wollen geht es weiter man fahre ich nach
frankfurt oder heute halt an dem tag an
dem ihr das video sieht keine ahnung
wann ihr seht
da ist ja wohl klappt auch cool ich habe
das video hat euch gefallen falls ja
könnt ihr gerne nach oben lassen
wirklich so persönlich sehr freuen wenn
euch dieser block gefallen hat ich weiß
nicht ob er gut wird oder nicht